ce sont deux anciens quartiers
industriels les aciéries de la Chine
d'un côté avec leur pont roulant le
secteur bridge Bonaventure de l’autre
avec son potentiel aux portes du
centre-ville la mairesse de la Chine a
présenté sa vision qui se rapproche
parfois du rêve mon pouvoir aller comme
sur la Méditerranée sur le bord de la
Méditerranée où on peut aller au
restaurant manger après cette baigné au
coucher de soleil où tout le monde est
beau tout le monde est bronzé les berges
non pour l'instant rien de méditerranéen
et surtout la transformation du secteur
telle qu'on la souhaite dans le nouveau
plan particulier d'urbanisme n'est pas
pour demain c'est sûr que c'est une
vision sur du long terme on parle d'une
vingtaine d'années et la condition
sinequanone un transport en commun
structurant qui pourrait rouler ici sur
la rue Victoria c'est impossible à faire
sans par exemple un tramway investige de
lignes rose que fustige l'opposition on
est rendu présentement à cette étude sur
la ligne rose à travers la ville
Montréal mais on se rend compte qu'il y
a rien qui avance autour du bassin pile
plus à l'est les développeurs veulent
accélérer la cadence et ne plus se
perdre en consultation faudrait pas
arriver que nous tirs réglementaires qui
vont encore nous prendre trois quatre
cinq six ans pour commencer à faire
sortir de terre ce nouveau quartier en
2025 ils vont devoir s'entendre avec la
ville qui prévoit 7500 logements soit
2000 de moins on le sait là c'est très
polarisé dans le secteur de bridge
Bonaventure faut qu'on s'assure que la
densité qu'on souhaite avoir là-bas soit
réparti de façon intelligente mais comme
pour l'ancienne hippodrome ce nouveau
quartier aura besoin que les pouvoirs
publics et privés soient inventif pour
le financement
un milliard deux milliards de dollars à
dépenser dans ce coin-là que ça soit en
décontamination en route en rue en
infrastructure publique en restauration
du patrimoine
qui va payer ça comment va le payer et
comme pour la Chine pas de développement
sans transport pour l'instant le REM ne
fait que passer la construction d'une
autre station n'est pas encore acquise
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal